you're not a tattoo guy are you I'm not
a tattoo guy right now yeah you have no
tattoos
so I have one tattoo actually I had it
in that picture as well but it's in a
place that's very discreet can you be a
little more elaborate please yeah that's
right it's right over here
join a lair it's sort of over near there
in the pubic region yes yeah yeah near
the pubis yes yes that's where that's
where it is yes I do feel like this is
turning to a trial very good and why did
you get it there
well is it pointing the way what you
know turn right here big plenty of fun I
think it was more I'm sort of an
ownership thing my wife said why don't
you get a tattoo and I I guess maybe it
was based on the idea that if ever I I
thought maybe a you know a peccadillo
outside the marriage was was a good idea
that whoever might be you know would
read that this particular piece of
equipment was already signed by someone
named Kate that's a very strange yeah
label on it all right
well Wow okay we're gonna take a quick
break I have a lot to process much more
mr. Kelson grandma just sent cigarette
you